hello everybody lies this year welcome
to a brand new segment of this channel
called cringe of the week let's get
started shall we
so this week's cook cringe of the week
is gonna be on little punk Thank You
Elias for that intro you may have heard
of young famous rapper love pump before
little pump which of course is famous
for his intricate lyrics little pump ooh
low pump yah little pump ooh
low pump yeah low pump ooh low pump yah
little pump ooh little pump yah for
gucci gang gucci gang gucci gang gucci
gang Gucci gang Gucci gang gucci gang
gucci gang gucci gang gucci gang gucci
gang gucci gang thanks but little pump
is not just famous for his rap genius
okay he's also famous for his overall
genius his beyond Rick and Morty level
of genius they would you say was the
difference between America in the United
States the United States is more south
and America is down here even if he what
he's saying is making any sense
it's double not making any sense he must
patrol he must be trolling there there's
no way someone is this stupid but you
don't understand little pump like I do
okay he's a genius when he's saying
north and goes down he's talking about
how polarizing our current climate is
and how the world just seems like it's
turn upside down north for you might be
south for little pump and America for
you might be USA for another person it's
like completely different things
little pump is living in two different
time line and once open your eyes people
and if you criticize they'll pump then
you don't understand he's genius
I think his haters needs to be scattered
people love love pump okay ask anyone
he's not really saying anything I mean
he said you about like ten times and
there was really no substance to that
song I'm not really feeling it this
woman doesn't know what she's talking
about don't listen to her okay she
doesn't understand the true fire and the
true meaning with a little pump okay
what else what else does she has to say
I mean it just sounds very generic it
sounds like everything that's kind of
out right now but kind of look in the
lower level I agree
the pump has transcended our language
okay our simple words are not enough to
describe what he means does anyone even
know what a scare it means now some
people have tried okay some people have
tried to deconstruct well pumps lyrics
genius calm has tried their very best
Gucci Gangu chicane Gucci gang Gucci
Gagne spend three racks on a new chain I
[ __ ] a [ __ ] I forgot her name by saying
I [ __ ] a [ __ ] I forgot her name Lowe
pump is addressing to his listeners that
one-night stand relationships constantly
occur within his life he shows this by
saying I forgot her name meaning that
the relationships that he forgets the
girl's name recurrently this line also
shows well pumps listeners that Lowe
pumps leads with girls on their regular
I should touch you see it touches your
soul you're hot you're going 70 miles
per hour I don't want to take you to
drive 70 miles 70 nigut Oh fly 70
explain to the camera was one time
seventy seventy one time 70 is 70 so
anything about one where do I come from
you're going 70 miles one time 70 is
cemani you don't get it do you one time
70 is 70 open your eyes now let pump is
no stranger to flexing you know he's
come very far and he's he's not shy
about it at all
here he is in first class flexing his
chain at the party on a little plane
you know that first class that's like 60
extra bucks on an airplane like this
okay
no wonder flex pump come on everything
Gucci first-class baby
it's a regular airline Meritus as scared
a you know I have been defending love
pump for a very long time now and I
think I've been wrong love pump isn't
just the genius here's God okay
when you die this is what you're going
to hear now that's music now that's
music to my ears play that again please
oh okay all right okay all right so for
real though I I think some of these
songs are good they're good to listen to
I don't think everything has to be I
have deeper meaning or extra thought it
would just be boring if everything
everything was trying to have a deeper
meaning so you know take it for what it
is I know he gets a lot of [ __ ] but you
know it's still so good get some good
songs there I'm trying really hard here
one like equals one is skating
[Music]